hello everyone and it's been a while
since I did a magnus carlsen video so
here's a fun one for you
this game was played in 2010 it was
played in the Chess Olympiad in Russia
and Magnus Carlsen is playing with the
black pieces against the Sun and ceiling
of a very talented young Russian Grand
Master who already won the World Youth
Chess Championship twice so in this game
it's Magnus Carlsen who is actually
playing against the world champion a 2
times world champion so Surikov is the
white and carson is black we have E for
lacrosse and placed c6 the caro-kann
defense we have d4 d5 and series of
plays efile the advanced variation so
advancing gets pawn to e5 we have a
Bishop to f5 Knight to f3 and b6 and ok
across entrelac is light square bishop
and this is definitely a plus side but
downside to this is well that he already
spent 4 moves just to develop this slide
squared bishop so we have Bishop to e2
Bishop to b4 check by Carlsen and now
Knight the b2 developing a piece Knight
to d7 we have a castles and now Bishop
to a5 we have a Knight to b3 attacking
that Bishop and now Bishop this is c7
and out Knights the e1 a wooden idea and
here Carlsen tries to break a white
center he plays f6 and well white
immediately jumps with his Bishop a
bishop to h5 check and here Carson plays
g6 but if he played something like
Bishop to g6 to try and exchange pieces
and maybe improve the position this
would this wouldn't be so good as well
f4 here is excellent for white and the
threat of Bishop captures and g 6h
captors and g6 and queen g4 stone in the
position
so after this car across and replied
with g6 and superego played Bishop to e2
and the g5 now inviting the whites to go
for Bishop h5 again but then King t7 or
f8 the black King will be completely
safe now so we have Bishop to d3
Bishop to g6 and now he captures on f6
Queen captures on f6 and our Queen to g4
threatening this g5 pawn we have h6
and how's your ego plays F for we have
Bishop captures on b3 Knight captures on
d3 and now queenside castle and okay it
seems seems that Carson got his King to
safety and all's well those pawns are
going forward it seems like Wyatt is in
trouble so we have Bishop to d2 and now
Queen to g6 by Carlsen and here as you
do gets a brilliant idea
he plays Bishop pick up sorry F captures
and g5 and now constant rise attack if
he plays Knight to f6 trying to exploit
the fact that well this pawn cannot
capture this night as the Queen is
undefended but your ego plays rook
captures on f6 and now we see well of
course now the rook cannot be captured
is if Knight captures rook
for example if Knight captures rook then
Queen captures here and wall serega will
capture this night would upon next
because the black ink is in check and
after he moves this winds to pieces for
a rogue this is quite good for white so
after rook captures and f6 crossed and
tried Bishop captures on h2 so he's down
on a piece and well he decided to
sacrifice a piece and if sirak of the
well would capture this bishop you would
get something like if King captures on
h2 you get
you'd get H captures and g5 with check
now I discover check from this rook on
h8 King to g1 and now Queen captures on
f6 capturing this rook Bishop captures
on g5 now hearing the Queen and the rook
and a queen to g6 and well of course now
the bishop is pinned as the Queen is
stolen protected and this is what Carson
was going for and he might get a nice
attack here with both Brooks and g8 and
h8 probably the knight would also get
into the game but after Bishop captures
on h2 studio simply played King to h1
and well what do you do now
Carson decided to capture the rook and
we have Queen captures on e6 would check
we have Kings to be eight and now G
captures on f6 we have a bishop to c7
because the bishop was attacked on h2 we
have a Knights the e5 Queen to c2
we have f7
we have rook h2 effaith blocking that
pawn and surah kahf simply plays a very
simple move that wins the game
immediately he plays Bishop to b4 and in
this position magnus carlsen resigned
the game as well Carson is already down
a piece and the well after this rook
moves or anything
this white pawn becomes a queen and then
rook captures Bishop captures and he
loses the exchange as well and this is
over so yeah definitely a nice game I
wouldn't say this is really the worst
loss micros Carson ever experienced but
it's definitely one of the hardest this
is moved to 25 so this is considered to
be a miniature so not a lot of people
and managed to do this against Magnus
Carlsen even though he wasn't the world
champion champion yet he won the World
Championship in 2013 so four years after
this game was played but still you know
his Magnus Carlsen so yeah that's it I
do hope you enjoyed this nice game by
the future world champion and the
current two times world champion and I
would like to thank Carl Krinsky for a
contribution to my channel I really
appreciate it and I did put your message
it was a very nice message to send me
with your donation so thank you what and
yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here and I will see you
soon thank you all for watching